so I'm sure you heard the news out of
Ireland Ireland once a devoutly Catholic
country but no longer voted a few days
ago to repeal the amendment that
prohibits abortion in their country so
another way putting that is they voted
to remove human rights from unborn
children they voted to unperson unborn
people
and it was a landslide 64% in favor of
killing children in Ireland 34% against
twice as many four as against and this
was I believe basically an exact
reversal of what the ratio was when the
amendment was first passed Ireland like
the rest of the West Ireland has been on
a steep cultural decline for many
decades and it ends here it ends in in
in
salutes moral relativism and nihilism
and bloodshed that's where it always
ends many most of the Western countries
had arrived at that point a long time
ago it took it took Ireland longer
because Ireland was much more steeped in
faith so it took them longer to arrive
at that point and it's a very very sad
they especially for people like myself
who have Irish heritage it's a very sad
thing to witness and I think it's
interesting to note this is kind of a
separate conversation I'd only go to
sidetrack maybe I'll do a separate show
about this but it's interesting to note
that in Ireland there's been a very
steep decline in church attendance
that's that is correlated with all the
other with there with with the general
cultural descent and of course again a
car across the West this has been the
case that fewer and fewer people every
year are going to church certainly it's
been the case in our country but it's
been a very dramatic decline in Ireland
because if you go back forty or fifty
years ago or even maybe even more recent
than that like thirty years ago you
would find that in Ireland basically
everybody goes to church right and now
the vast majority of people don't and
it's no coincidence people stopped going
church stopped practicing their faith
like that and then you have things like
what happened this weekend in Ireland
and I the main reason I want to wanted
to note that is because it our country I
often will talk to Christians who will
claim that going to church doesn't
matter and it doesn't really matter if
you go to church or not it's not
surprising at that point of view is so
prevalent because church attendance is
becoming a rarity in America but so I
talk to Christians to say what's your go
to church doesn't matter
if that's the case that it doesn't
matter
then why is it
that there is always a correlation
between a country losing its faith
and a country and the people in the
country not going to church anymore
why why is it that those things are
always connected
people stopped going to church and the
faith thing a decline in church
attendance always coincides with a
decline in faith always there is not one
single example in the entire world
of a country where the people stopped
going to church but the faith remained
strong not one single example why is
that
why is it that in every country or
people stop going to church the faith is
suffering enormous ly
it's kind of interesting is I mean it
would seem it would almost seem that
going to church is a really important
thing
actually practicing your faith that way
collectively together is extremely
important and when you stop doing that
everything else falls apart that's how
it would seem unless you can point to an
example just give me one example of just
one one country where the faith is very
strong
and people are on fire with the faith in
their country
and culturally the country looks exactly
as you would expect it to look it's not
legal to kill babies you know gay
marriage isn't doesn't exist families
are strong marriages are strong the
faith is strong but people don't go to
church give me one example of that just
one
so anyway
people were jubilant in Ireland the
streets were filled with tearful happy
people who are overcome with joy because
they can kill babies now
abortion will be legal up until 12 weeks
and after that abortions will only be
legal where the health of the mother is
at risk but you have to look at the fine
print there because health of the mother
includes mental health so if the mental
health of the mother is at risk then you
can get abortions after 12 weeks as well
which means that abortion is effectively
legal after 12 weeks also because mental
health is a is a qualifier that can
justify literally any abortion because
any woman can say well my mental health
will stop for if I have this baby and
there's no way to disprove that
whatsoever so you know abortion is legal
up till 12 weeks and Beyond in Ireland
now I wanted to read a little bit from
just because I think it's very revealing
so and it's also revolting I'm just
warning you but order to read a little
bit from the CNN report on this scene in
Dublin after the after the the the
results of the of the vote were
announced so it says
it was a scene of jubilation as some
supporters burst into tears others began
laughing as they hugged one another and
asked each other can you believe we did
this
Emma Gallagher 22 began crying as she
heard the final results I feel safe now
I feel comfortable
she told CNN it felt for a long time
women didn't matter now we know that we
matter except for women who females in
the womb you know they don't matter but
Rene Wogan 66 held Gallagher's hand and
told her it was all for justice you're
forwarding the flag for all women
thousands of people packed the square in
front of Dublin Castle as abortion
rights politicians including the Irish
prime minister also joined the
celebration he told Sky TV he expected
legislation to be voted through by the
end of the year another woman says I
feel enormous relief and great pride in
the people of Ireland who didn't who
didn't know what they thought about it
until they were finally asked the
question it has been a long and very
hard road but we've never lost sight of
this because it's so central to the
existence and the selfhood and the
personhood of women to have that control
over our bodies
killing babies is central think about
that
killing babies is central to the
existence of women
think about that state
abortion is central to the existence of
women
and it's the only way that they can have
selfhood and person they a court
according to this person abortion women
cannot even have a self they can't even
have cell phone they cannot even be a
self without without the ability to kill
babies
and not just kill babies but kill their
own children
a competition you see
in the minds of pro boards
it's like there's a competition there's
this eternal struggle between women and
their offspring
and women in Ireland just won the
competition
you
now as I said it was in reality a sad
sad day for for Ireland and Irish people
and I assure you of this that history
will look back on scenes like the one I
just described though they will look
back in scorn and contempt and ridicule
and they will judge us swiftly and
harshly and fairly for our sick
enthusiasm for killing babies and and
the other thing is when when history
looks back on our country in America or
Ireland or anywhere else in the west
where this goes on there's not gonna be
any nuance to their judgments it's just
like when we look back on slave owners
we don't make any attempt to understand
their position with nuance or to you
know understand in context or whatever
we don't do that we look back on slavery
and slave owners we sight so it was we
say it's a it was a it was a terrible
debased evil and these were all evil
people and that's it
that's how they will live for the
entirety of the rest of the human race
or that's how they'll exist in our minds
right and that's what people will do in
yep later on when history looks back on
this era the abortion era if for one
thing abortion will be the thing that
defines us nothing else just like
slavery defined that era abortion is
what defines us
and nobody's gonna take the time to
understand it in context or anything or
understand it with nuance they're just
going to write off our entire era our
entire civilization as a bunch of
bloodthirsty self worshiping baby
killing Psychopaths
and they won't be wrong
they will not be incorrect and we will
deserve their judgments
but this story and and the enthusiasm
and celebration that surrounds it it
does illustrate one important thing that
the pro-abortion left despite what they
may claim the pro-abortion left they do
not see abortion as a necessary evil
okay it is it is to them it is it's not
a sad thing that is sometimes necessary
they may claim that nobody likes
abortion nobody is pro-abortion every
time I use the phrase pro-abortion I
have pro-abortion people who say well
nobody's pro-abortion what are you
talking about nobody's nobody's in favor
of abortion it's just that sometimes
it's necessary we need to have that
right for women and the unfortunate
situation the tragic situation where
it's necessary we need to have it
available to them
you
but
not the case just look at the jubilation
and the tears and the just
ecstasy of these people in Ireland
they love abortion they are happy when
babies die they are happy about it
if you tell them in America you know 60
million abortions 60 million babies are
dead hey they're happy about
the people like this the kinds of people
that were in the street in Ireland
crying tears of joy
they're happy about racking up those
numbers
they love abortion it is not a necessary
evil it is in their minds a necessary
good
if it were otherwise okay if they were
really just pro-choice and not
pro-abortion and if they just thought
that will a woman has to have this
choice but it's really unfortunate when
the choice needs to be exercised then
there wouldn't be all of this
celebration the response to this vote in
Ireland would be somber and muted and
restrained they wouldn't be throwing a
parade in crying tears of joy because
they would recognize that even in their
minds you know from this perspective
they would say to themselves okay
well it's good that women have this
right this nest is necessary right but
it is going to result in it you know in
a lot of bloodshed and that's a very sad
unfortunate thing it in their minds it
may be a necessary thing but it's very
sad and so that's how they would react
or they would not be crying tears of joy
and saying we did it we did it yes and
throwing their their arms up in the sky
and just yes babies are dying hooray
they wouldn't be doing
they do that I mean it's very simple but
when you see people celebrating and
crying tears of joy in the street
and you find out that they're doing this
because abortion is legal they love
abortion they are so pro-abortion I mean
they are more prone than they are Pro
anything else it's the thing that they
are most in favor of in life
support for us to understand that the
pro-abortion left is is led by people
like this
this is what you find on the
pro-abortion left leading the way are a
bunch of people who really do love
abortion it's their high sacrament they
revere it they bow before it they have a
it is a high holy beautiful thing to
them and they have they really have a
reverence for it and they approach it
with a satanic enthusiasm it's the only
thing I could really can compare the
enthusiasm to is uh is you know when
I've read about
I've read a couple of very fascinating
books about the Aztecs and especially
Cortes and the Spanish conquistadors and
their how they how they conquered the
Aztec people which was a great a great
moment for it for human history and a
great victory that I still thank God for
that the Aztec civilization was
destroyed because it need to be needed
to be destroyed it was the Aztec
civilization was easily the most satanic
civilization that has ever existed the
most evil twisted satanic perverted
depraved bloodthirsty civilization has
ever existed on the face of the planet
and I would probably include even I put
it even below the Nazis or above that
point you know however we're phrasing
that but the human sacrifice that went
on in the Aztec civilization was just
beyond anything you can imagine in tens
of thousands and there weren't that many
people you know we're talking about a
few million people probably so this this
is with tens of thousands of humans
often children were slaughtered in human
sacrifices every single year and there
were cases there was one case what one
instance where a new temple was built
and to kind of coronate this temple they
sacrificed tens of thousands of I think
was something like 80,000 people in the
span of a couple of days
sacrificed on on this temple to baptize
it in the blood of these sacrifices
and the way that they did these these
sacrifices as they would take usually
these were you know prisoners that they
caught slaves they also demanded
tributes to be paid by all of the all
the different tribes that they had
conquered and subjugated they demanded
these tribes provided tributes of human
sacrifices on a you know on a regular
basis to keep things going and which is
one of the reasons why when Horton
Cortez came he had no problem enlisting
other Indian tribes to help him defeat
the Aztecs because they had all been
enslaved by this barbaric horrific
civilization of of bloodthirsty
cannibals so anyway they would bring the
the the sacrifices up to the top of the
temple they would lay them on a slab and
the high priest would cut open while the
person's still alive they would cut open
the person and rip their beating heart
out of their chest and then they would
push the the dead bodies down the temple
steps and the wing limbs would be hacked
up and eaten at the bottom of the steps
okay this is what this is what went on
among the Aztecs there was this real and
Cortes himself is one of the ways we
know about this is when the Europeans
witnessed this stuff going on you know
and it was just unlike anything they'd
ever seen or could conceive of
but there was this like they went into
this trance they went into this real
this demonic trance this almost orgasmic
ecstasy that they had when they were
killing and devouring people
and the reason I bring that up is
that's the only thing I can think to
compare the scene in Ireland with people
in the streets again this almost
orgasmic ecstasy
over
the mass slaughter of babies it's the
only thing historically that I can think
the comparative
you
so and those are the people like the
height like the Aztec high priests who
just love abortion and they really see
it as a just it's it's it is like a
sacrifice to their satanic gods and it
we must do this we must kill these
babies they are they're the ones who are
leading the way
not just among on the pro-abortion left
but on the left generally and of course
to distinguish pro-abortion left from
the other kind of left that doesn't make
any sense because there is no other kind
of left the left is pro-abortion
you know and you can't be on the left if
you're not pro-abortion so they're the
ones leading the way and then at kind of
the lower level you have sort of the
mass of pro-abortion people the majority
of pro-abortion people and they perhaps
don't have the same kind of enthusiasm
they're not going out into the streets
and crying tears of joy about it but
they also neither do they have anything
approaching somber restraint they are
empty and numb they see the sacrifice of
human children as necessary and good
though they still get a certain kind of
queasy feeling in their stomach about it
sometimes but then they feel guilty for
having that feeling and they try to
suppress it
they are pro-abortion they are they are
not restrained about it and they really
are not sad about they don't see it as a
sad thing
and these two groups the bloodthirsty
abortion enthusiast and the admiring
abortion supporter they comprise the
majority of the pro-abortion left now
way way way out on the fringes you have
a few
people
who really do hold to the pro-choice but
not pro-abortion mantra in that they
really don't like abortion and they find
it detestable personally but they just
can't bring themselves to call for its
probe for its prohibition because
they've been so brainwashed and
indoctrinated but they you know they
really do acknowledge within themselves
this is a sad and terrible thing but
because they've been brainwashed they
think that oh it's it's necessary for
some reason those people
the people like that it's a dwindling
minority of people but there is there's
there's definitely hope for them they
have a heart still they have a
conscience and so you can reach out to
them and connect with them
there is a there's a
there's some kind of common ground
because you both acknowledge that
abortion is a sad and terrible thing
it's just a matter of where do you go
from there right so those people it's
not too difficult to connect with them
and to bring them over to bring them
bring them into the light but the rest
the kinds of people who are you know
just so ecstatic and enthusiastic about
abortion
well they they need a miracle
they need prayer they can't be reasoned
with
okay you can't argue with them
only the Holy Spirit can change their
minds by changing their hearts
decides to hand them over to their
depraved passions then that's where
they're going to stay
and we may have to figure out some other
way to oppose them because there beyond
the reaches of debate or argument the
people like that
[Music]
you know like I said it ordered a reason
with someone and to convince them you
have to be able to connect with them on
some level
and if you're dealing with someone who
is
whose eyes are welling up with tears of
joy over the thought of dead children
and if you're dealing with someone who
thinks that the very existence of women
is it hinges on the ability to kill
their own children well someone like
that you know you you can't connect with
them on any level at all
they barely have any kind of human
conscience anymore
so we have to pray for them
very very hard
and find you know we have to go and look
and find any of the straggle or is any
any of the remaining quote unquote
pro-choice people who still have a
conscience and do recognize in their
hearts that this is evil we got to find
them first and enlist them because they
can be reached
then once we're left only with the with
the with the people with the satanic
enthusiasm for killing babies well then
we have to decide where to go from there
but it's a sad day for the world and so
let's pray for my Erland and for the
West and for our souls
and for these children
the many many children who will now die
because of this
thanks for watching everyone thanks for
listening Godspeed